THING, YOU KNOW, THE THING.
THE THING.
JOINING US WITH MORE FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KATIE
PAVLICH.
KATIE, THE THING WOULD BE GOD,
OUR CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
THAT’S THE THING HE FORGOT ABOUT
THE THING.
>> YOU KNOW, SEAN, THIS REMINDS
ME OF WHEN HILLARY CLINTON HAD
THAT MEDICAL SITUATION WHEN SHE
CLASPED ONCOLLAPSED ON 9/11 IN N
CITY.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO IGNORE IT AS
IF IT WASN’T A BIG CONCERN FOR
THE BIGGEST JOB IN THE WORLD.
JOE BIDEN HAS CLEARLY MADE SOME
MISSTATEMENTS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL JUST TWO WEEKS AGO ON "FOX
NEWS SUNDAY" HE HAD A LENGTHY
INTERVIEW WITH CHRIS WALLACE AND
AT THE END OF THE INTERVIEW
CALLED HIM CHUCK AND THEN SAID
THAT HE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND HOW
PEOPLE DO EARLY MORNINGS.
SO, THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS ABILITY TO KEEP UP ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PROBABLY PRETTY HAPPY ABOUT THIS
LOOKING LIKE IT’S GOING TO BE
HIS EVENTUAL OPPONENT BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
CAMPAIGNING FOR OVER A YEAR NOW.
HE LOVES DOING IT.
HE HAS A LOT OF ENERGY.
AND HE IS EFFICIENT WHEN IT
COMES TO GETTING -- TO RUNNING
THE WHITE HOUSE AT THE SAME TIME
AS BEING ABLE TO GO OUT AND
CAMPAIGN FOR RE-ELECTION.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, SARAH, ONE
THING I WILL SAY, I MAY SURPRISE
PEOPLE.
BERNIE DOESN’T SEEM LIKE HE HAS
HAD A HEART ATTACK.
WITH ALL THE MODERN MEDICINE
TECHNOLOGY STENTING, BYPASS IN
BETWEEN.
THE GUY HAS A LOT OF BALCHEVIC
ENERGY ON THERE DOESN’T SEEM TO
BE STRUGGLING ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND A YEAR OLDER THAN QUID
PRO QUO.
>> CERTAINLY HAS THE ENERGY BUT
NOT THE IDEAS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I FEEL LIKE IS
LOST, ANYBODY THAT HAS BEEN
WATCHING JOE BIDEN ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL OR THE DEBATE
STAGE KNOWS HE IS A TERRIBLE
CANDIDATE.
BUT, LET’S NOT FORGET THAT
ANYBODY WHO IS ALSO PAYING
ATTENTION KNOWS THAT HIS
EXTREMELY LIBERAL POLICY IDEAS
WOULD MAKE AN EVEN WORSE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS A BAD CANDIDATE.
HE WOULD BE EVEN WORSE AS
PRESIDENT OF THIS COUNTRY.
HE IS SUPPORTING TAXPAYER FUNDED
ABORTION.
FREE HEALTHCARE FOR ILLEGALS.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL, WHICH WOULD
BE DISASTROUS FOR THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY AND AMERICAN JOBS.
HE IS NOT A MODERATE THAT THEY
ARE CLAIMING TO BE.
HIS POLICY POSITIONS ARE LIBERAL
AND HE WOULD BE A TERRIBLE
PRESIDENT FOR SO MANY REASONS
JUST LIKE BERNIE SANDERS WOULD
BE TERRIBLE AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT, WHETHER IT’S BERNIE
OR BIDEN, HE’S IN GOOD SHAPE
GOING UP AGAINST EITHER ONE OF
THESE TWO GUYS.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE POSITION
OKAY ON HEALTHCARE, KATIE FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, OPEN
BORDERS.
THEIR RADICAL POSITION ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEIR RADICAL POSITION ON GUNS
AND -- OH, GREEN NEW DEAL, LESS
OIL AND GAS.
THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY.
FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS WHERE
ENERGY INDEPENDENT WILL GO BACK
ON THAT.
, WHAT WE ARE GOING BACK TO
DRIVING MULLAHS IN IRAN.
GO BACK TO 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS.
8 MILLION MORE IN POVERTY AND
THE LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RATE SINCE THE 1970s?
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO THAT?
HE HAS A RECORD.
BURST MARKS KATIE, IS NOT GOING
AWAY EITHER.
>> NO, IT CERTAINLY IS NOT GOING
AWAY.
THAT CAN OF WORMS HASN’T EVEN
BEEN COMPLETELY OPEN YET.
JOE BIDEN HAS ADMITTED HE WANTS
TO RAISE TAXES AND REPEAT TAX
CUTS WHICH FOR A VAST MAJORITY
OF AMERICANS ESPECIALLY FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS IN THIS COUNTRY.
HE HAS PUT BETO O’ROURKE IN
CHARGE OF GUN CONTROL POLICY
WHICH THAT MEANS GUN
CONFISCATION WHICH IS COMPLETELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND IF EVERYBODY BELIEVES IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT SOMEHOW
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO SWING THE
PARTY BACK TO THE MIDDLE FROM
THE LEFT, THEY ARE COMPLETELY
AGAINST WHAT THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION IS IN THAT PARTY.
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO GET EATEN
ALIVE BY THE LEFT WING OF THE
PARTY.
THE AOCs, THE ILHAN OMARS,
NANCY PELOSI COULDN’T EVEN
HANDLE KEEPING THEM TOGETHER IN
THE HOUSE WHICH LED THEM DOWN
THIS ROAD OF IMPEACHMENT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOT TO MENTION JOE BIDEN WHO
CAN’T EVEN STAND UP TO THESE
IDEAS AND PUT FORWARD HIS OWN
PLATFORM WHEN IT COMES TO BEING
OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL IN A
REAL MODERATE WAY.
HIS POLICIES ARE VERY FAR LEFT.
AND, YET, WE ARE STUCK WITH THIS
TALKING POINT THAT HE IS SOMEHOW
THE NORMAL ONE WHO EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE VOTING FOR.
>> Sean: AND LOOK AT -- SARAH
SANDERS, YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HAVE BEEN AROUND PRESIDENT
TRUMP HE HAS GOT THE ENERGY OF
LIKE 10, 30-YEAR-OLDS.
>> I’M UNDER 40 I’M PROUD TO
SAY.
AND DONALD TRUMP HAD MORE ENERGY
THAN ME EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT I
WORKED FOR HIM THAT TO THE POINT
IT’S ALMOST EMBARRASSING HOW
MANY CIRCLES HE ROSE GARDEN
AROUND THE REST OF US.
>> Sean: I GO HOME ON THIS TRIP
I WAS TALKING TO HIM.
LEAVING VIETNAM AND JUST HAD
THIS INTERVIEW EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO BE SLEEPING.
I’M ONLY ONE GOING TO STAY UP.
THEY ARE ALL LAYING OUT ON AIR